soil itself contains within it many many
things that can help the investigator
work out what has happened at a crime a
week ago we Bernie the packet of drugs
in this particular location I've taken a
new team here today and they're tasked
with seeing if they can find out where
these drugs might be buried as we're
approaching the scene we're looking
around for particular clues as to where
the perpetrator may have come in so
we're looking for vegetation that might
be flattened disturbances to the soil
maybe a raised profile where there's
material that's been buried beneath it
after the tape has been secured around
the crime scene the next thing we have
to do is to make sure that we've decided
on the appropriate routine and to put
down the protective plates so that we
don't stand or contaminate the crime
scene in any way we make sure we've got
the full crime suits the scene is
protected from us contaminating it with
anything and also protects us from any
potential contamination that may have
been left behind by the perpetrator
who's been at the scene we wear gloves
because we don't want to shared any DNA
on to the crime scene we can see a
little bit of raised grass here so what
we need to do is carefully lift that
turf off and see if their husband a
disturbance to that natural soil profile
the mock scene of crime is an approach
that we use to carry out research
because as you can imagine when you have
a real case you cannot do any testing or
any experimentation of any of the
methodologies at that time what we're
trying to test here is the use of
microbial soil forensic science so
that's the use of the microorganisms and
soil as indicators of where someone may
have buried something or where someone
may have stood back in the laboratory
what we'll do is we're going to extract
the DNA from this soil in fact you know
in a teaspoonful of soil you've got more
microorganisms then you have people on
the planet so there we've got a wealth
of information and what we do with the
DNA is we run it through a
next-generation sequencer so these
approaches give us a fingerprint and we
can compare the fingerprint we've got
with a contextual soil that we know was
at the scene with the fingerprint that
we get on their fenders boots or on the
speed that's been left behind in the
boot of the car it is a relatively new
method it's used in the Netherlands at
the moment and I think that's about the
only country in the world that it is
used in court so what we want to do is
we want to test it within the different
soils that we have here in the United
Kingdom before we use it in court it's a
very exciting time to be part of this
new wave of soul forensic science